so Michael welcome to punch you're all
glad to be here how does it feel it's
your first time here in Montreal right
yeah it's my first time in Montreal
obviously not my first time in Canada
you know it's the festivals it's a lot
you guys for Less festivals a lot so I'm
sure when you come when it's not going
on it's a little different but I'm happy
to be here the people are really nice
I'm brushing up on my French yeah it's
not going well because I got like a New
York
French accent so but it's cool you know
having a good time up here and the
people are like I said a really nice
I've eaten some good food got a little
little taste of Montreal who to you the
Chinese poutine I haven't yet I'm trying
to make a special I like there's been
some sort of raggedy ones I want to
start at the time it's a lot routines
like half full of meals I'm looking
forward to it is there any difference
with Canadian audiences do you find um I
don't think I haven't noticed that I
mean I think for me for me specifically
there's some things that don't translate
slang wines just the way I speak but so
far I feel like the audiences have
gotten everything that that I've said
and you know it's either funny or it's
not funny there's been a couple of just
words here and there that I've noticed
that just slip by um but but I mean this
is kind of like the best comedy
audiences you could ever ask for because
people are coming to the festival for
comedy so they're there just as there's
an earnestness about the audience and as
a comedian you appreciate that yes so I
mean you're still acting do the stand-up
yeah good to the podcast world like how
you find in the podcast room I love the
podcast world the reason why I love the
podcast in doing my podcast I am
Rapoport stereo podcast is because
there's absolute for my podcast there's
no rules right and regulations and that
to me is the most fun you could say what
you want say it how you want say it for
as long as you want or as short as you
want
there could be non sequiturs and you
know you could start talking about your
blue shirt and then you know you don't
have to finish you know it's just
talking and and there's there's a
messiness that's allowed in a podcast
it's as unlike
a television or film or even comedy even
comedy that gets even freer than comedy
so I really really really love doing the
podcast yeah I think even in the
description of your podcast like it says
like Michael's offensive opinions yeah
and we're in such an age of PC you were
in such a PC and and and you know and
and I feel like there's a lot of
performers that aren't abide into it you
could feel audiences whether you're
doing stand-up or online and and and and
you know it's it's it's an interesting
thing because people are people are
scared to laugh in public people are
scared to say they relate to something
which is like another layer another
layer you know they like you could catch
people laughing of resisting laughing
because they're like oh I don't want to
look like laughing it's like we're going
to another layer and it's not it's not
healthy listen we're no puritanical --zz
I'm not pure puritanical I just met you
I know you're not puritanical dico
everybody and and and to try to front
like we are me humorous is made from
from pain the best humor obviously
there's different kinds of comedy and
stuff like that but for me like that the
political correctness is just it's just
ridiculous and it's so it's so phony
right it's so fake it's so it's so faked
it to think that you don't laugh at
things are you don't you know like the
basic thing to pie in the face this is
not something you're supposed to laugh
at right like if I told you like it's
all that's mean-spirited now you can't
throw a pie in the face that's like as
old as it gets so it's an interesting
time but I just try to continue to do my
thing and and with my stand-up I try to
make fun of that and you know put myself
on on blast and you know and then once I
think once you put yourself on blast you
know you're sort of telling everybody
like everybody's open right every
everybody's you know anyone could get it
I say that you know like anyone could
get it let's say think of me and if
you're gonna really be equal equal
rights yeah you talk about women you
know everybody everybody should get it
so let's thing I know you're on like
Twitter and Instagram yeah does it get
exhausting sometimes too I mean I know
you got it from like ariana grande yeah
yeah we've done a few times known shows
where we talk about you soothe performs
or something
we get it like does it get exhausting to
get that like just inundated with that
hate when you when you have certain
opinions on things it doesn't you know
at first I think it was exhausting and I
think it was scary
oh no I've said something that's but now
I'm just like I I get what it is and I
know the ramifications of it and I Anna
and I'm so I'm offended by your being
offended so if you don't get to humor
and you don't get the jokes and you
don't get the fact that from me
personally like I make fun of myself
right first and foremost you know I'll
play the fool and make fun if you don't
get that you're just not getting it you
know like but everybody's looking to
take the next person down and you know
you know I call it America's next top
racist everybody's looking for America
next up racism there America's next top
you know anti-feminist and all stuff so
it's just it's just it's not exhausted
like now I just kind of lean into it is
it with social media I wasn't really
aware that anyone was paying attention
to me now I am aware of it but but when
I put things out I just put it out like
I had a thing we're never second-guess
yourself no but I know no but but
because for the most part it's just you
know something comes in my head and I
just put it out and then then it might
be afterwards then you have to like you
know double down and like I don't know
Mecca but but also I think that if
you're gonna talk crap me you know
sometimes you're gonna step on people's
toes and if you step on people's own you
might have done something I didn't mean
that to come off the way it's okay to
apologize I'm not one of these people
who says well everything I say you know
I stand by that's that's not realistic
you know sometimes you do offend people
sometimes you you you you can say
something that you didn't intend to be
interpreted a certain way and if you do
that and you feel like it's important
enough you can acknowledge and be like I
didn't mean that
so that's part of the game too like I'm
known as well I stand by everything I
say I'd be crazy to stand by everything
I say yes to your histogram story I
guess last thing here in the hotel room
James just said mama right here yeah
damn right I'm a fan of summer I mean
everybody loves Mariah Carey I mean
she's so so prolific in the air songs so
iconic but there's a couple of songs
that
when I get I mean that's why the songs
are so big because there's a couple of
songs that when they when they I'll get
him in my system it's like it's like
it's like I can't get off the treadmill
it's just like I'm on a Mariah treadmill
and that's one of the song she's amazing
I so sweet if you've seen some of her
stuff against someone just having a clot
or montage recently that she always
walks in a frame during an Instagram
video and she has nothing to do with the
face app once nothing to do with that
it's funny social media is good because
you get this from from celebrities
you'll get a sort of sense of like Halle
Berry has a cool Instagram you kind of
get their like their template right
there says you're like that you look to
the does that really well because anyone
for you that you oh that's a celebrity
there's not so much celebrities I would
say that the one person like I'm not
like a big huge Halle Berry film but I
my wife say oh the checker pages just
kind of arty um I would say her that's
off the top of my head I would say
that's my one Halle Berry I think that
would be good but then there's like you
know people like you know there's like
all these funny people social media that
I think is interesting it's a whole lot
of media matter now in terms of just
flaccid we have so many people here yeah
what's it like being part of this huge
comedy vessel people don't realize I
mean you walk through a hotel lobby yeah
there's just comedians yeah yeah yeah
everyone you've ever seen on tone yeah
movie or anything up on the stage so
what's it like being part of this it's
it's cool you know I've been a part of a
lot of film festivals I've never been a
part of just for laughs and comedy is
that a edge I mean comedies went through
different phases of heights you know
there was like the disco era of comedy
like in the 90s in the 80s when it was
just huge and and then and then it kind
of slowed down and now it's at a
different there's so many different
kinds of comedians but just for laughs
is dope like you know seeing comedians
uh in the elevators and running into
them and you know and you know what
watching Wanda Sykes just work out some
stuff last night it at this one woman a
it's it's really it's it's cool and it's
a pleasure for me to be here and you
know I just started back into comedy so
I'm really honored to be a part of
of this year's festival
you